so Democrats had debate - night - last
night again because of the number of
candidates the second debate split into
two nights I told you after the first
night that the winners for me were the
sort of growing Bernie Warren coalition
both doing really well some people
thinking Bernie did better than Warren
some people Warren better than Bernie
but significant consensus that they both
dominated that debate followed sort of
hilariously in a way by Marianne
Williamson who talked about dark souls
or dark energy or something like that
but she actually did do better than
everybody else on that stage other than
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren that
was night one night - last night it was
much less clear who won per se but I
believe that the strongest in - in night
two were Andrew yang and Joe Biden now I
want you to just hear me out on this
okay this is I know this is something
that many in the audience aren't going
to agree with I believe that Joe Biden
ended up doing well last night simply
because the sustained ganging up on him
started to fall flat and fail okay I
don't like condescending to the audience
but I want to issue disclaimers
I don't think Biden won because he said
anything extraordinary
I don't think Biden won in the sense
that he appealed to actual progressives
Biden is one of the more center-left
candidates on stage not one of the more
progressive candidates on stage but
basically what ended up happening is
that no one stood out in any reasonable
way other than Andrew yang which I will
get to and Biden merely by sustaining
attacked attacks that became more and
more a sir flaccid for lack of a better
term ended up doing okay so here's what
happened in the first debate not the
first night of this debate but I mean in
the first debate back in June
the most memorable what we call a kill
shot moment which are these sort of
gotchas that are only they're really the
only way to do well in a debate whose
format is so ridiculous and and prevents
any sort of depth depth on issues the
his memorable kill shot from debate one
was where Kamala Harris went after Biden
over race related issues and case in
point it worked
she surged four points between debates
the most of any candidate there were a
couple people who gained two points
Biden was roughly even Burnie lost two
points so the candidates other than
Biden came in last night clearly
planning to attack Biden however they
could as the old guard of the Democratic
Party which is sort of true as not
really progressive which is absolutely
true and at first it went okay like
there was a moment where New York City
Mayor Bill DeBlasio started going after
Biden and the attacks were pretty good
and he got Biden in a situation where
Biden clearly didn't want to answer
about deportation under the Obama
administration then Booker sort of
jumped in and Cory Booker and Bill
DeBlasio we're tag-teaming Joe Biden and
made him look not progressive which he
is not but then the attack started
falling flat and kirsten gillibrand for
example thought she would jump in on the
action and her attacks on Biden just did
not work and Biden ended up looking sort
of as the rational elder statesman that
everybody around was trying to attack
when Kirsten Gillibrand sort of failed
in her attack on Biden Kamala Harris
immediately tried to jump in her attacks
also felt sort of fell sort of flat so
as not progressive as Biden is as much
as he is not you know his politics are
not my politics I'm trying to tell you
what I see as the attacks on Biden
ultimately backfiring and leaving Joe
Biden looking stronger from having
weathered what was clearly a decidedly
joint effort even if they didn't speak
about it everybody came in with the idea
of most people on the stage to attack
Joe Biden and before you furiously email
me I'm not a Biden supporter I'm not
saying I like the policies he laid out
he was talking about many issues in
language that is almost the same as a
moderate Republican okay all I'm saying
is he went in polling in first place if
you're a casual follower of the
Democratic Party and you see Biden look
calm and collected admittedly low-energy
as well while half the stage is just
trying to attack Biden instead of laying
out their vision I believe that it helps
Joe Biden hugely now secondly I believe
Andrew Yang did really well and I know
people will say oh but David you
you've taught you've interviewed him and
you clearly have some kind of bias
towards Andrew yang my primary biases
towards Bernie and Warren in terms of my
politics I did not think Andrew yang did
well in the first debate he barely got a
chance to speak and he did well last
night despite by the way yang was the
fourth in terms of polling on the stage
last night and from the analysis I saw
this morning that producer Pat sent me
he got some of the least speaking time
and yet he still did really well Andrew
yang gave a really good answer framing
medicare-for-all as something that's
good for small businesses which really
reverses the Republican talking points
on the issue he worked in his thousand
dollar-a-month freedom dividend in a
more natural sounding way than usual one
of the criticisms of Andrew yang is he
often goes to that freedom dividend in
ways that seem very forced and they
don't really land in a way that you
would want he did much better on that
that he gave a really strong answer
about reality TV politics that the crowd
love take a look there with makeup on
our faces and our rehearsed attack lines
playing roles in this reality TV show
it's one reason why we elected a reality
TV star as our president
we need to be laser focused on solving
the real challenges of today Andrew yang
also talked about literally moving to
higher ground because of climate change
which is sort of imagery that provokes
an urgency that a lot of other
candidates failed to provoke a lot of
discussion about climate change but a
lot of the candidates rhetoric really
falling flat in terms of pointing out
that we are in a crisis and Rianne did
really well there
so if I step back and try to look at the
two nights together which is hard
because you don't have everybody on the
same stage Bernie and Warren I believe
are the big winners the the strong
progressive coalition the left is an
important part of the Democratic Party
they crushed it on night one together on
night - I believe Biden by weathering
increasingly flaccid attacks against him
is probably going to at least sustain
his polling Andrew yang I would guess is
going to pick up some polling otherwise
I don't think that the zeros and ones
really benefited from either night of
these debates my prediction would be in
terms of polling and will maybe have
some of that by Monday some of the 0 & 1
support will start to just go away
and consolidate around Bernie and Warren
I think Biden will basically be
unchanged and yang will pick up a little
bit now serious question a bunch of
people during my live stream yesterday
on twitch at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman we're saying what asking whether
I think any of the candidates are taking
pharmaceutical you know drugs to calm
nerves or whatever I actually it is an
open question for me as to whether at
least some of the candidates were on
some kind of downer or
anxiety medication I believe it was
Michael Bennett who seemed kind of like
Fred Willard in terms of delivery the
guy from best-in-show
very slow and and very strange pauses
Hickenlooper night one I don't know I'm
curious what people think I can
understand being nervous enough to reach
for something to calm the nerves but
there it's something that kept coming up
yesterday during my livestream curious
to hear from people about that we do
need to get down to just one one evening
one stage by the third debate
September 12th and 13th or maybe just
the 12th if there are a few enough
candidates and we maybe there are only
seven candidates right now who have met
the requirements for the third debate
that's Biden Budaj edge Harris Sanders
Warren Booker and O'Rourke Andrew yang
had met it but now some recent polls
pushed him out we'll see if he makes it
in there's still time for who Leon
Castro and potentially Tulsi Gabbard to
get in on there they're there on donors
but they're not really polling well
enough so the group will be smaller come
September 12th but how much smaller
still remains an open question let me
know what you think about who comes away
the winners